there is outrage following very
disturbing video out of a North Carolina
middle school gotta warn you this is
really tough to watch take a look a
school resource officer is caught
slamming a student to the ground twice
yes
he'd NEX a student up before dragging
him down of a hallway so this happened
last Thursday Advance County Middle
School the officer has been placed on
paid leave pending an investigation by
the state the school district says it is
fully cooperating with the investigation
that officer should be able to come back
and the thing about it lettuce the
student is so little
kitty under said it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter this Judy's sister says
she'll be okay he's at home recovering
they're investigating this but when you
look at that when I first read the
research I thought okay it might be a
teenager and I saw the video and you see
something essentially he was walking I
mean he was walking up to this student
administration office and I don't know
what provoked it whatever it is just
walking I mean I'm already endorsed us
but paid leave nearly a zone so the DA
is looking at possible charges depending
on the injuries of the tile